bungie is coming up on its 30th
anniversary and the developer has all
the momentum in the world dropping the
dopest reveal for destiny 2 the witch
queen and kicking off the annual hype
cycle once more if you're into destiny
or all things gaming be sure to drop a
like and sub to this channel as well but
before we start i want to quickly
mention one thing if your opinion of
destiny 2 is based on the game from
prior years honestly just save yourself
some time this video isn't really for
those who want to just stop by and tell
me that the game is dead it's got over
20 million new players we're having a
blast with some of the best storytelling
in world building in years and bungie
has shown no signs of stopping or
catering to the folks that have no
intention of playing so do me a solid
stop it
get some help now if you're like us and
you're excited for this expansion then
all i can say is welcome and let's dive
into everything you need to know about
destiny 2 the witch queen
to start it off we have to talk about
the witch queen herself savathune is one
of the primary antagonists of the
destiny universe but so far we've only
dealt with her brother oryx during the
taken king expansion and her sister sivu
arath during this season of the hunt
savathun is more cunning than her
siblings and has been pulling plenty of
strings behind the scenes from
evaluating our capabilities as guardians
during the season of the splicer to
taking riven the last amkara and
unleashing a curse cycle upon the
dreaming city now she's out in full
force welcoming us to her throne world
and daring us to survive the truth but
what does that mean
the truth in the witch queen expansion
seems to be that savathun has been
gifted the light giving the hive brand
new powers on par with guardians and it
is a sight to behold as we face
salvathun's loosened brood hundreds of
hypestyle ghosts frantically search the
battlefield reviving fallen hive
combatants and resurrecting them with
terrifying new powers many of which look
like our own but are now being wielded
against us there is one distinct feature
that separates the hive ghosts and it's
the fact that it doesn't quite look like
their powers of the light are one-to-one
with the guardians guardians get their
light from the traveler's ghost and
savathun is notorious for being cunning
and a trickster of sorts which leads me
to believe that the powers of light that
are granted to our enemies are merely
some kind of illusion or trick of being
in her throne world on bungie's launch
page for the witch queen the developer
alludes to this with the section
covering some of the new activities
labeled solve the mystery pierce the lie
a lot of the teasers leading up to the
reveal of the witch queen were also
framed with quote survive the truth
which supports the idea that what we're
seeing from savathun is just another one
of her intricate webs of lies and
deception and that we'll be spending
most of our time trying to lift that
veil so beyond the campaign the witch
queen will be chock full of different
content like a new six player match made
activity at the heart of the throne
world details are slim at the moment but
there's mention of balance needing to be
maintained each season so far this past
year has had some kind of a six player
match made activity such as season of
the splicers override and they all play
with similar themes of guardians
basically playing the role of
maintenance and keeping the environment
balanced or progressively inching closer
towards an ultimate goal for the season
finale there will also be a new raid and
more raids and dungeons to look forward
to post-witch queen as well raids have
been pretty dry this past year with only
two raids released in over a year and a
half which is quite the drought for some
of destiny's best and most memorable
endgame content so far we had the deep
stone crypt last year with beyond lights
launch and the reprised vault of glass
and season of the splicer but this time
around we're getting a brand new raid in
the witch queen the raid takes place in
the swamps of savathun's throne world
and lies in a sunken pyramid some of you
may already know the pyramids are kind
of the symbol for the darkness and we've
traveled inside one of them before
during shadow keep i am so excited and i
can't wait to see how a raid inside one
of these massive ships will be
especially inside savathun's throne
world it's also been confirmed that
older raids will be reprised and
returning so there will be more raids in
the near future which is great news now
the jury is out on whether older raids
from destiny 1 like crota's end will get
the remaster treatment or if bungie
simply plans on cycling out raids like
the last wish to make room for something
from their destiny content vault like
the leviathan personally in regards to
the destiny 1 raids coming back i get
tired of revamped content pretty quickly
despite enjoying the nostalgia at first
but there are millions of destiny 2
players that have never seen this
content so i have no issue with more
reprised raids to help stem the content
drought between seasons we've covered a
good chunk of news so far but let's
shift gears towards some of the other
types of content and gameplay changes
for starters the witch queen has a
difficulty modifier on its campaign you
can try to sweat it out on legendary
mode which means you can earn even more
powerful gear and extra rewards there's
also weapon crafting a first for destiny
there's an argument to be made that the
current umbral engram system could
qualify as a sort of crafting but that
is really kind of its own thing in my
book with umbrals you can invest certain
materials to try to dodge the rng of the
game a little bit by curating your loot
drops you can make an engram for example
drop a piece of armor with a high
mobility stat but you're still not sure
what kind of armor piece you're gonna
get or from what set but you're banking
on the mobility stat being decent enough
to potentially rotate into your armor
lineup with weapon crafting and the
witch queen it seems like we're taking
things a step further by being able to
craft all witch queen and seasonal
weapons and even trying hunting for
specific perks to craft with crafting
there's also the brand new glaive
destiny's first and only first person
melee weapon the glaive is a versatile
new energy weapon archetype that lets
you use melee combos mid-range
projectiles and defensive capabilities i
won't even lie to you it looks sick as
[ __ ] and i'm excited to see the class
specific exotic variants with all this
dope new content to look forward to it
begs the question for destiny 2 fans
which version of the witch queen should
you get to briefly summarize you have a
standard edition a deluxe edition and a
pricey collector's editions which at the
time of this video is actually already
sold out so
they all kind of speak for themselves if
you're a casual or new player and you're
unsure if you want to stick with destiny
throughout the year then the standard
edition is for you it's a fairly
complete experience with all of the
witch queen's content but it doesn't
come with the seasonal activities the
deluxe edition is your best bet as
there's plenty of seasonal content worth
diving into like dungeons exotic weapons
and other bits of content the
collector's edition is obviously for
fanatics like our very own phil hornshaw
who knows every little thing there is to
know about the lore and has some wicked
good lore articles for newcomers and
veterans alike destiny 2 the witch queen
is basically on the same tier as the big
fall expansions of the past despite
having a february 2022 release date
before the bungie activision split the
taken king and forsaken were massive
content drops after bungie went
independent their large fall expansions
like shadow keep and beyond light were
hefty but not nearly as grand relying
upon the seasonal content and season
pass to kind of help pad the stats a
little bit so to speak that being said
though all the expansions were an
absolute must play that first month and
ever since bungie moved on from the
stale and monotonous small scale dlc
like curse of osiris and warmind they
have found better ways to keep the
content fresh on a regular cadence even
though it might still be a bit of a drip
feed for the hardcore players who pump
dozens of hours a month to where they're
spending the majority of their time
trying to like solo or two-man
encounters that usually have six players
it's also worth mentioning that pvp
deserves more love and although there
have been great threats from the
developers talking about focusing on pvp
post witch queen there are obviously
things to be wary about but where's the
fun complaining about all that man it's
[ __ ] destiny we're getting a new drop
in february with brand new weapons sick
ass armor new raids new activities new
story new everything i'm so excited to
kick some hive ass and i hope you're
down to come along for the ride too
until next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you